in the right hands the relationship
between man and suit is symbiotic the
suit has power the man
harnesses that power you need to be
skilful agile and above all you need to
be fast you should be able to shrink and
grow on a dime so your size always suits
your needs now dying through the keyhole
Scott in charge big you dive small then
you emerge big when you're small
energies compressed so you have the
force of a 200-pound man behind a fist
hundredths of an inch wide you're like a
bullet you punch too hard you kill
someone too soft it's a love tap in
other words you have to know how to
punch I was in prison for three years I
know how to punch
show me terrible you don't show me how
to punch show that's how you punch
she's been looking forward to this no
kiddin
hope trained in martial arts at a
difficult time by difficult time he
means when my mother died we lost her in
a plane crash it's bad enough you won't
tell me how she died could you please
stop telling me that lie we're working
here alright princess let's get back to
work
were you going for the hand
[Music]
you know I think this regulator is
holding do not screw with the regulator
if that regulator is compromised you
would go subatomic
what does that mean it means that you
would enter a quantum realm what does
that mean it means that you would enter
a reality where all concepts of time and
space become irrelevant as you shrink
through all eternity
everything that you know and love gone
forever
cool yeah if it ain't broke you've
learned about the suit but you've yet to
learn about your greatest allies the
ants loyal brave and your partners on
this job
[Music]
character kyanite longicorn is commonly
known as crazy ants they're lightning
fast and can conduct electricity which
makes me useful to fry out enemy
electronics that was a lot scarier a
second ago
you